six is less than two times the absolute
value of X minus three minus four is
less than 12 okay so it's a compound
inequality this whole quantity here is
greater than six and less than 12 so
here's how you would approach this
problem first thing is you want to work
towards the variable okay from the
outside in so we're trying to get this
variable by itself so the first thing I
would do is I would add four okay to the
middle the right and the left side of
the inequality so that gives us 10 is
less than two times the absolute value
of X minus three is less than 16
okay still working from the outside in
and we're going to divide the middle by
to the left side by two and the right
side by two so now we have five is less
than the absolute value of X minus 3 is
less than 8 okay now what we're going to
do here is we're actually going to split
this up into two inequalities okay like
this so what we have is we have X minus
3 the absolute value of is greater than
5 notice I flipped it over
okay the inequality okay and we have X
minus 3 the absolute value of that is
less than 8 okay so now what radios are
going to solve these separately so here
what I'm going to do because this is a
greater than problem we're thinking or
okay and this one is a less than problem
and we're thinking and okay so that's an
important distinction and so what we're
going to do is we're going to split this
up into two problems we've got X minus
three is greater than five okay
or X minus 3 is less than okay negative
five we can notice I change the
direction of the inequality sign and I
also multiply it by negative one if you
want to see this from a different
perspective what you can do is you can
think of here we're dealing with the
positive case okay whatever was in here
original could've been positive or
whatever was inside the absolute value
here could have been negative but if I
multiply both sides by negative one what
happens to the absolute sorry the
inequality sign it changes direction
right and so this becomes we're
multiplying both sides by negative one
this becomes negative
five and when you multiply or divide by
a negative number that inequality sign
flips right okay so continuing on if we
add 3 to both sides X is greater than 8
or add 3 to both sides here X is less
than negative 2 okay for this problem
because it's a compound and you know an
an problem we can write this as a
compound inequality X minus 3 is less
than 8 and greater than negative 8 okay
so this is kind of a quick way of
writing these problems these absolute
value inequality problems when it's less
than you can write it as a compound
inequality so I'm going to add 3 now to
the middle the right and the left side
of this inequality so we get negative 5
is less than X is less than 11 right
okay now what we're going to do now keep
in mind that we split this up right into
two parts right if we go to the number
line and we graph this okay what we have
here is we have let's see we've got
negative 5 we've got negative 2 we've
got 8 okay and we have 11 okay so let's
graph this one here first so X is in
between negative 5 okay and 11 right
okay and then over here we have X is
greater than 8 right or X is less than
negative 2 okay but I want you to notice
that see how this is and when you see
the word and that means an intersection
or where the solution sets overlap and
you can see that they're overlapping
right here and right here so our final
answer is going to be from negative 5 to
negative 2 okay and then also this
region here from 8 to 11 so if you want
to write this as a solution you could
say X is greater than negative 5 and
less than negative 2 or the or means in
math it means Union or both X is greater
than 8 and less than 11 now if you want
to write it in the interval notation
what you would do is you would say
negative 5 to negative 2 Union 8 to 11
and the parentheses those curved
brackets
represent that it's open okay so it's
not including negative five not
including negative two it's just in
between negative five and negative two
so this is a pretty challenging compound
absolute value inequality problem and I
hope you picked up some pointers here
and subscribe to the channel check out
some of my other videos on Mario's math
tutor and YouTube channel and I look
forward to seeing you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon